do we finally know what luffy's real
dream is not to become pirate king but
the one that hola sensei has only hinted
at in his flashback with sabo and ace
the exact same dream that also roger
hats and that inspired people like
crocus shanks and rayleigh to put all
their faith into a rubbery boy to change
the world well i think that chapter 1049
of one piece really seems to suggest so
at the climax of the epic battle between
luffy and kaido both of them attacking
with what seems like their last ultimate
techniques the emperor asks luffy what
kind of world he wants to make if he's
actually strong enough to change it and
in a series of three absolutely
incredible double spreads luffy replies
that he wants to make a world in which
his friends can eat and drink as much as
they wish
i can't even begin to explain the sort
of goosebumps that this gave me now why
do i think that this answer not only
makes a ton of sense but more
importantly also wonderfully embodies
the main theme and message of one piece
as a story because there is a lot packed
into this little statement one big
theory that i heard being thrown around
a while ago is that luffy's real dream
might be to have a giant banquet with
all of his friends based on the fact
that the end of every major arc and
victory for the crew kind of has luffy
celebrating it with a feast which
honestly i think was really close but
did not quite hit the mark because just
one giant banquet would imply that
luffy's biggest desire would be having
one giant event with all his friends
laughing and feasting together which i
absolutely do think will happen don't
get me wrong but it doesn't quite
address the main theme of the story
freedom the fact that luffy wants to
make a world where everyone can eat as
much as they want in friends and food
the two things that he loves the most in
this world implies that he wants him to
have the freedom to live the happiest
life that he can imagine in other words
to me it's kind of the most looty way of
saying that he wants to liberate the
world it takes luffy's biggest quirk as
a character eating like there is no
tomorrow and connecting it to the
central moral message of one piece which
i just found absolutely beautiful the
banquets that luffy had so far always
are a celebration of life among equals
that now are free to do whatever they
like eat drink sing dance because as we
know at this point luffy is basically
friends with everyone in the world
except those who stand in the way of
everyone else's happiness in a world
where most people live in poverty and
despair ruled by a small group of people
that have all the wealth and luxury i
would argue that means that luffy's goal
is to take down the world nobles and
free the world which ironically is
exactly what kaido's goal is who's
flashback by the way i'm just pumped to
discuss in just a moment of course as
well and so even more awesomely is
possibly a word
well now it is even more awesomely the
theme of eating and drinking as much as
one likes not only references the story
as a whole but of course also connects
wonderfully to the themes of wano in
particular as well a country that is
starving and has no clean water to drink
an arc that literally started with luffy
being gifted the little bit of thomas
rice that she actually had to eat and so
he shouts his dream for a better world
at the climax of the raid on onigishima
where kaido has been holding a yearly
banquet with all the food and all the
drinks anyone could want but only for
his men and those few who are actually
in power and so even though luffy and
kaido share the exact same goal in a way
freeing the world
kaido has taken the wrong path to get
there becoming what he hated the most in
the process don't you find it ironic as
well that we see kaido literally
declaring war on the nobles that took
away his freedom and that of the people
he loved by creating a de facto system
of world nobles inside mono itself
because that is kaido's big flaw as a
character that in the end only luffy
will be able to make him see and realize
it's actually very similar to big mom i
feel nada think about it because she has
created an actual country made out of
food also pretty much based on luffy's
dream only that here the people are of
course not really free to do whatever
they want and live a happy life though
let's be real it's a lot better than
wano indians and so two of the yonkos
have basically started where luffy did
only that where kylo and big mom lost
their course somewhere along the way and
turned into villains luffy will be the
one who actually succeeds in making this
stream a reality most importantly
without becoming the bad guy in the
process i mean that's what always has
made luffy special and why i love this
chapter and the reveal of luffy's actual
dream so so much also did you notice how
young big mom is very similar to young
luffy genuinely kind and caring or how
young kaido in this chapter basically
looks like a young luffy but with horns
and actually since we're on the topic
right now let me share my thoughts on
kaido's flashback that we got in this
chapter as well okay so as you will
notice i absolutely loved loved the
overall story of how kaido became the
person who is today and i will go into
detail here in just a moment but i do
have to get this one thing off my chest
first because if this is gonna be
everything that we're gonna get for his
past that would be way too short for me
personally at least this is the final
villain of not only the longest arc in
all of one piece but also the entire
yonko saga past the time skip i mean
kaido has gotten a ton of absolutely
next level character development during
onigishima but i just really really want
to see
more details and more interactions from
his past like at least an entire chapter
two or three or four i want to see more
of kaido interacting with young big mom
and white beards and i do get that oda
sensei is probably saving a lot of that
for when he's actually gonna reveal
rocks and his past but still i really
think that kaido is interesting and
important to the story right now not
like a hundred chapters from now and so
if this is it if this is all we're gonna
get
not quite long enough for me personally
i want to see more however that being
said what gives me a lot of hope
honestly that we will see a lot more
from kaido's past is the fact that we
still don't know a lot about for example
what he was experimented on how he
recruited the rest of his men how he
learned about joy boy in the first place
and so on and so forth so truly fingers
crossed or some more the flashback that
we did get so far though content-wise at
least was just so good
i mean i love the fact that kaido is
from a kingdom that's literally called
vodka given that he is a pretty bad
alcoholic how he made a name for himself
as his country's strongest warrior at
the age of 10 only to be sold after the
marines by the king for the chance to
get more power by getting access to the
referee he basically comes from an
island that did war and plundering as
its main job to raise enough money for
the heavenly tribute which is basically
protection money a country has to pay to
the world government to not be attacked
by them actually it kind of feels like
the world government is sort of a mafia
that runs the entire planet actually and
so this explains a lot of kaido's
character traits he has known nothing
but war ever since he was a little kid
really he has learned to hate the world
government as they're responsible for
his childhoods and being sold and
betrayed by his entire country i
absolutely love that oda sensei baited
us by saying that kaido was captured and
executed a bunch of times by the marines
but as it turns out most of the time he
just escaped and let himself be
recaptured whenever he became hungry
which is not only the most hilarious
explanation for the strongest creature
being captured that often but it also
ties in surprisingly nicely with the
food theme of luffy's dream again
another really interesting detail in
this entire thing i found was once again
big mom's interaction with kaido because
it really seems like these two used to
have a much closer relationship than we
originally thought linlin is almost
behaving like a big sister here and is
shocked to find out that kaido once
again vanished after rox was defeated by
garvin roger he vanishes a lot it seems
and again we still don't know how this
all played out but it sounds like at
least these two were pretty close even
after whatever went down at god valley
but in a way the most important reveal
in this entire chapter to me at least
was something that i had already been
speculating for quite a while now and
was nice to see confirmed because kaido
basically confirms to us that he's been
trying to bring about the return of joy
boy and while king thought that it would
be kaido himself kaido was waiting for
the one who could defeat him which is
why he was so disappointed at the
beginning that luffy couldn't defeat him
only that luffy came back not once not
twice but three times if i'm counting
correctly each time stronger and more
determined than before and the fact that
kaido remembers this conversation with
king at the moment that he's punched
down by luffy to me really shows that he
is almost relieved and happy that luffy
has delivered such a massive blow and
has been able to push him this far i
mean even the flame clouds have vanished
which by the way has finally triggered
momo into fully summoning clouds of his
own and so now the big question is of
course is kaido defeated or not while
all of this clearly sets up our
expectations for kaido being defeated
here and luffy having run out of steam
too i personally would like to think
that this fight isn't over i mean luffy
has come back a number of times in this
fight already but kaido hasn't had to
pull off a full comeback even once so
far i also still don't quite believe
that we've seen his awaken form yet and
i would honestly like this battle to
continue on for a little bit longer i
feel like kaido will stand back up at
some points however it doesn't
necessarily have to be against luffy
really i think the last panel shows us
that kaido has realized that luffy is
joy boy and is acknowledging his power
luffy has overcome him in this moment
and so i would absolutely love to see
kaido getting back up to defend luffy
against the government forces or
blackbeard or whoever it might be that
might try to take luffy out while they
still have the chance and so kaido
defending joyboy and inheriting his will
to free the world onto luffy would be a
fantastic redemption arc for his
character i think that for whatever
reason i really want to see for kaido
actually if you want to know why you
really can't ignore this analysis video
of kaido i've done and if you've enjoyed
this video why not subscribe to the
channel for more